ah je suis très très heureux de vous
revoir franchement j'étais avec vous à
fond en peluche et passive où l'on dit
un peu on vous l'a dit vous êtes content
d'être là ah oui c'est vrai aussi
fm vous avez coupé un peu les cheveux
depuis des élections non merci en tout
cas être là alors qui peut nous donner
le nom de miss france malama chavez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va pas applaudir une personne
parce qu'elle bosse sur ces dossiers on
n'est pas là pour ça qu'on a franchement
on travaille on est là je connais très
bien son prénom au ciel voila voila
merci valérie merci d'être là vous êtes
donc une miss france 2010 9
vous avez revu est-ce que vous avez revu
l'élection vous allez vous la voyez à
chaque fois qu'on veut faire une télé
elle s'arrête tout seul et puis avec les
copines ah ouais c'est vous avez le
temps de voir vos copines depuis depuis
que c'est vous avez été lui aussi que
miss france normalement vous êtes élue
miss france vous même quoique vous
partez dans une boîte houston ont battu
alors écoute moi bien on va te mettre
une couronne sur la tête tu vas partir
en peugeot 306 tu vas partir loin de
tout ça écoute moi bien si tu entends
quelqu'un qui demande de couper du
saucisson celle au maire jean fête du
village japonais de venir tout de suite
on te voit plus beaux frères wertheimer
qui n'a peint que will kate vous madame
c'est que je ne connais pas à côté moi
je ne connais tu as quand même eu le
temps alors vous avez quand même eu le
temps d'avoir de voir vos amis sa valeur
mais il ya quand même des moments où il
faut qu'on s'arrête à la station pas ma
[ __ ] loin c'est ça qui est embêtant
parce qu'on est miss d'une région plus
retourner dans sa famille mais quand on
vient de on habite à dix mille
kilomètres conflit civil
mais la loi c'est la plus beau s'appeler
malfrats ce que j'ai entendu une
interview alors on vous avez un petit
récapitulatif de cette soirée folle du
15 décembre
vous avez vu votre avenir basculer ici
je vous le dis avant l'émission en a
beaucoup qui avait fait de vous leur
favori ah oui moi je me dis moi benjamin
kelly vdev lui maxime gainey est ici
tout le coup un petit peu plus âgées
n'avaient pas vu le truc arriver oui
c'était sur l'élection de 1981 qu'a dit
françois mitterrand
regardez c'était le 15 décembre
c'est le 15 décembre dernier en direct
du zénith de lille que maeva cook miss
france 2010 8 transmettait sa précieuse
couronne devant 7,4 millions de français
haweij malama chaves miss tahiti 2010 8
miss france 2009 et miss tahiti
[Musique]
une victoire particulièrement symbolique
pour la 89e édition du concours puisque
cela faisait tout juste 20 ans qu'aucune
miss tahiti n'avait remporté miss france
très vite va et madame à chavez s'est
imposée par son style très particulier
aux impatients
[Musique]
dès la diffusion de son portrait lors du
concours la miss a séduit une grande
partie du public avec son ton naturel et
sa fraîcheur polynesia m'ont fait
confiance et compte sur moi pour
apporter la couronne de miss france à ma
région et ce soir c'est pour toute la
nation que je souffre
m
et durant toute la cérémonie miss tahiti
s'est montré à la hauteur de tous les
tableaux sous les yeux d'un jury 100%
féminin conquis par les prestations de
la jeune femme
est ce que le choix du public a
correspond au vôtre parfaitement
d'accord avec elle était spectateur
des veilles manama s'est aussi illustré
par une déclaration choc sur son poids
qui n'a laissé personne indifférent
j'ai longtemps été rendu et c'est
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur de
partager aujourd'hui j'ai confiance en
moi et je max
bref autant de détails et de singularité
qui ont fait de vagues malama chaves une
miss france pas comme les autres aussi
atypique que touchante et qui en
quelques semaines seulement semblent
déjà avoir conquis le coeur des français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui comment vous trouvez physiquement
mais france 2019 a franchement à laurent
chauvier lire vaima là bas je voulais je
le dis aujourd'hui et je le dis devant
la france entière
c'est ma miss france préféré de toutes
les missions sur l'histoire des bois
cyril ça veut dire cyril si la dent à
l'instant vous recevez un coup de fil de
miss france venait tout parce que c'est
notre heure il ya des voix là est qui et
qui vous demande alors réitéré
alors il est bien confirmée voyez vaima
la main oui je le confirme rien mais on
dira même malade qu'est ce qui va se
passer
oui oui série regardez ces images soit
il ya quelques temps prendre favorite
c'est miss tahiti
ah oui elle est géniale bon c'est pas
que c'est pas mon délire s'il vous plaît
souvent c'est pas mon délire mais elle
est allée pas mal oui mais s'ouvrir
jeudi la viande et c'est d'aller là
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans le métier je
vais le dire aux téléspectateurs
c'est apparemment vous débutez dans
l'audiovisuel ce qu'on appelle un binic
ce qu'on appelle même voilà pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent un
gaming de situation quoi vous savate
alors vous vous je vous le dis mais
souffre et la bile
je vous le dis aimer nos bêta alors non
franchement vous êtes magnifique j'étais
à fond pour vous et je redresse et la
puissance la plus belle que j'ai jamais
reçu et je n'ai jamais vu des gens là
dans l'es9 donc et n'ait jamais existé
ah oui ce que delphine alors voilà c'est
pas le même délire non non non c'est oui
puisque dating puisque tout le monde je
le dis voilà j'ai pas peur de dire
qu'est ce qui va m'arriver
vous avez vous les censeurs verra le
fasse avec delphine ses fans au togo
[Applaudissements]
c'est surtout gaudray d'un titre elle a
rigolé l'oreille manama alors juste pour
nos téléspectateurs c'est que c'est une
question que vous pose à chaque fois
mais qu'est ce qui se passe du moment
franchement ou parce que c'est ça qui
est fou dans nos miss france c'est pas
comme par exemple un mec a un champion
de tennis
il sait qu'il a et capacités pour gagner
pour moi un mec qui chante quand on est
champion du monde de foot miss france si
vous êtes au médecin qui est en vous et
vous dites dont cinq minutes ma vie va
basculer
non mais c'est vrai ces flâneries on
vous une couronne et là c'est parti pour
un an et même pour toute la vie parce
que ça y est vous serez mix france à
dire et qu'est-ce qui sait qu'est ce qui
se passe depuis ce que vous êtes ce que
vous êtes trop des sons du nom ça plane
toujours
c'est vrai vraiment clair que les saints
c'est pas mal chez moi parce que ça
redescend pas dit que vous êtes encore
en apesanteur comme disait calogero
c'est possible parce qu'en fait plus le
temps passe et plus je m'épanouis donc
c'est vrai s'il est heureux comme ça oui
vraiment est ce que vous vous y avez cru
à quel moment vous et 10 avec moi parce
que quand on est toutes les deux ce que
vous étiez avec miss guadeloupe qui
était magnifique aussi
et moi je sais que comme on le dit à
chaque fois la place de numéro 2 des
mystères c'est la pire fin parce que
personne te parle personne tu appelles
un ya les cotillons qui sourit et on
fait venir tout les pousse toi tu
partais pas tu prends une peur tu te
dégage on oublie de la cites non mais on
oublie de citer la peau
c'est un truc de ouf c'est ça elle part
dans l'oubli tout de suite aux personnes
strict a pas de citer la première
dauphine l'année dernière je sais saga
mais c'est un truc de fou de toi parce
que tu es dans les miss mais personne ne
peut le dire mais c'est vrai nom mais
vous pouvez citer la première de film de
l'an dernier et va quoi là elles sont
réglées très forte à la réviser les
niches sociales c'est un premier voile
et avec madame de fontenay l'a été
revoir je devais devront alors deux ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
garros qui a perdu contre noah ville en
2000 en heure merci si on fait ça va pas
faire un quiz toutes les missions alors
justement là on va faire un couillon
voir si vous connaissez bien miss france
je vous posais des questions
vous avez joué tous ensemble attention
ils sont comme des fous
[Rires]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on veut
mais bon c'est bon on assez honorer ceux
d'une galette le prénom val malama
signifie en polynésien source de quoi
source de quoi wiwa sur ceux de joie non
sur seul espoir non de bonheur non par
contre côté d'écouté plutôt source de
conneries annonce de vie non sans bon
sens de vieillards du tiers de lumière
de lumière non il ya des lumières mange
des lumières alors lumière lumière etc
mais ça m'étonne que soit révoquée 10 ha
de lumière baïramova est malin c'est fou
la ccs et tous vous alors je vous le dis
avant que vous ne riez sur le plateau on
était dans le choix retenu en été dans
l'obscurité totale
c'était un truc de fou quoi qu'est la
jamaïque malama 24 ans en fait pour
lundi standard vous êtes très jeune mais
pour une miss france s'est fait partie
des plus vieilles miss france oui
c'était la troisième plus vieille c'est
vrai alors c'est quoi là je limite
ah ouais ouais c ou feu et on nage de
chiens pour isabelle et 24 ans étaient
la dernière c'était la première fois que
vous présentiez à miss tahiti
ouais j'avais essayé de me présenter en
2015 mais je n'avais pas été retenu dans
ses origines mais il pas possible il ya
il était fatigué ou coin
non c'était pas n'étaient pas prêtes
c'était pas assez mature c'est vrai
ouais mais là vous vous êtes sentie
prête et quand vous avez été élue miss
tahiti vous vous êtes dit j'ai une
chance d'être miss france ou pas non
quand j'étais petit je me suis contenté
de ça je feins c'est déjà ça vous
suffisait déjà c'était difficile
d'envisager miss mans ça avait l'air
inaccessibles à une époque alors pas le
talent à quel moment vous êtes 10 avec
moi quand vous étiez avec miss
guadeloupe à ce que vous êtes dit je
pense que ça va être beau minois autant
cette année les mains il qu'on était
face à face s'est il avait en fait il ya
une chance sur deux pour que ça soit moi
c'est comme toi quand tu étais avec
l'ani seulement il y avait une chance
sur deux que ça pète pas répéter
[Applaudissements]
combien de kilos vaima lama at elle
perdu depuis ses 18 ans on a eu beaucoup
parlé 20 kg 20 kg du buzz jeune davide
vous faisiez 80 kg vous étiez surnommé
le monstre des moyens d il ya des
personnes qui sont qui sont voilà qui
est un petit peu qui ont même un peu de
poids mais beaucoup de poids qui sont
très jolis à oui biensur désolé donc le
monde c'était où ça qu'on a surnommé le
monstre c'était au collège
non mais les ans les tarbais passage
même saveur
non non il y avait bien du tout je me
réveillais puis-je aller avec cet être
là à l'école et ça ça vous déprimez tout
ça ça c'était pas facile encaissé tous
les ans vous a touché bien sûr c'est ça
qui vous a dit que vous êtes dit un jour
je vais essayer de voilà de devenir
voilà me font je vais essayer de devenir
une reine de beauté c'est ça qui me
motive même pas c'est arrivé comme ça
quoi
en fait en quinze jours à jauger un
accident de vélo et puis j'ai pu j'ai
commencé un plan du poids et j'aimais
pas ça et donc je décidé d'aller mieux
en réadaptant ma façon de manger on
inclut en plus d'espoir on fait quoi
comme sport il y en a plusieurs que je
fais aussi de la musculation d'accord
fitness de l'athlétisme à huy
modern'jazz encore de tamure juste à
moulins un flat mûri c'est là bas ils
sont parce que bénéfique
[Applaudissements]
la vallée val éo sans danger
entraînements tous les matins frais à ce
qu elle n couleur ça aille mal à mattel
croisés durant l'été ronaldo va bien sûr
paul pogba le champion du monde que
j'adore paul qui avaient pu voir à
manchester
on a une photo vous l'avez croisé où cet
été ah c'était un restaurant à paris
tient à tahiti oui et c'est lui qui est
voulu qui a voulu faire une photo avec
vous c'est vous qui a voulu faire une
photo avec maintenant c'est moi qui ai
cliqué demandé mme cyr et vous n'étiez
pas encore mon siège très bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
au milieu de nos deux têtes là il ya une
tête en plus sa femme
c'est sa femme et moi que si sa femme
épouse là au milieu des deux têtes et
bien écoutez bon là on l'on rase
également ballon mais c'est vrai voilà
au milieu de vos deux têtes là également
il est une femme ça c'est fou ça
arrivera pas qu'il ait des problèmes
avec ça non mais là pas trop là mais
derrière vous inquiétez pas on connaît
ici il ya roger qui est derrière aussi
valeur et je finis les sept fois et vous
avez vu que jean-michel se tient à
carreau
oui bonsoir en parlant de ça j'aurais
aimé savoir si vous avez quelqu'un dans
votre vie qui nous appuient à votre
question me dire si j'ai un shérif oui
je chéris toute la france
[Applaudissements]
politique elle sans rigoler salomi sur
l'arc à vue non non c'est son gala que
c'était flippant
bon faut savoir c'est parce que tu crois
alors je mangeais aussi vu que je sorte
avec aix n'est pas mais l'anderson et
j'étais contente elle de la plante non
c'est vrai on a dit ça oui vous sortez
avec l'ex de pamela anderson
oui c'est pas moi j'aimerais bien savoir
le site alors ben on va alors je vous le
dis moi sur rien du tout on vous savez
on a une région exceptionnelle autant
trouver des images et des photos ils ont
du mal mais trouver des axes
[Applaudissements]
pamela anderson va dire tout de suite on
aura une photo et vous nous direz
bâtissez votre délire ou pas votre
délire non non c'est pas du matin la
guerre et fait du batteur comme ça alors
vaima la masse y jouer de plusieurs
instruments de musique lesquels ukulélé
oui ukulélé et guitare by malama on a
une vidéo de vous vous jouez du ukulélé
au bord d'une piscine avec votre maman
ah oui c'est magnifique franchement ça
et moi une meuf qui joue du ukulélé away
sur la tête de ma mère
quoi comment où daniel moreau chanel a
bien du collège c'est pas du label il
sait très bien que tous les mecs
[Musique]
le player
et alors alors vas y ma lame à ce que
vous pouvez nous faire un petit plaisir
est ce que vous pouvez vous faire un
blindtest improvisé on a une guitare ici
eux c'est la guitare c'est une guitare
que j'ai ramené de mon dernier concert à
louhans cuiseaux
est-ce que vous pouvez nous jouer des
choses elle va nous faut des choses vous
avez vous également chez vous on est
avec miss france
et c'est parti vous ne jouez ce que vous
voulez on va essayer de découvrir ce que
c'est d'accord c'est bon alors est-ce
que vous pouvez vous vous avez déjoué en
si bémol on rémanents pardon comme vous
voulez le pauvre savez bien mettre en
valeur ses rythmes c'est pas grave non
mais oui c'est bien moi ce coupon à dr
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
poupardin le dr house à la maison je
suis bien comme ça merci a été prévu
comme ça c'est parti en live à la masse
est parti
[Musique]
est ce que pour vous en faire un peu et
vous savez la chanter aussi
oui mais c'est pas facile c'est trop
c'est vous les attendez alors attendez
laissez moi faire comme ça qu'est ce que
tu as à j'ai bossé deux sens avec
francis cabrel
si vous êtes vous m'emmerdez là alors
bon c'est un beau message c'est un
bordel t'emmerde thomert paix avec ça
parce qu'à la base c'était laquelle à la
guitare de passe partout en fait c'est
parti attention c'est pas t il mal à ma
passion votation n'est pas on n'est pas
des mélomanes d'uffheim à la mâche pas
ses mots ce qu'ailleurs on a vu
francesca show prière si vous nous
rejoignez les 20 heures samedi en plein
de la night avec miss france c'est
indirect
attention 3,4
[Musique]
voilà
vous pouvez détruire
noura karim espaces et ces bas pour tous
le construit on tout le contenu
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a vraiment eu une telle schwan assuré
que dans un sauna chante hyper bien
voulu être chanteuse après les faire un
disque après vous pouvez vous faire un
auteur ne peut des trucs comme ça vous
avez rien d'autre si si on la demandait
à celle prévue alors
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai un petit plus il ne s'agit pas du
tout alors venir voilà alors j'adore mon
nom et je débarque mois ont des
ambitions à les imams par contre là je
sais pas celle que vous allez crever
sans tahitiens sont assez rares connais
très bien je vais vous donner le titre
vous inquiétez tout comme à dammarie
[Musique]
taiana
annie roma au passé
mnm à l'automne dans ta tournée au coi
j'adore ce kabyle ou gamme et non non
c'est pépé n'a cp pena pena a fait la
fête taurine à ces lingots à la corse et
ça fait est que c'était l'outil de
s'arrêter non cfa faillite et sa
faillite est d'accord je voudrais qu'on
applaudit stressant
[Applaudissements]